I was a woman with
a mind that was
disconnected from reality at times
um so a woman
and so
what an ending classic France but no I'm
just gonna say my mind needed to be
brought into alignment with the reality
of my body as opposed to
a body that needs to be brought into
alignment of the reality of your mind
I think
the whole trans thing
is a microcosm
of
a much broader problem so you know you I
was saying about
just a failure to
bring us bring the truth and reality
into alignment with the way you want
things to be or the way you think the
things should be so the whole problem of
the
the trans identifying you know movement
is
I want my life to be like this I really
um
or it should be like this like as I say
when I was a feminist it's like it
should be like this
but
reality always bites back
um and so you're always going to be at
odds like with reality and you're never
going to find peace while you're trying
to live outside it I mean we've got a
whole world of social media telling you
you can you can you can you can well you
can't and
you know the many detransition is a
testament to that and the people who've
been betrayed by that but
I think it's a microcosm of
a broader human problem so like I think
over the last best part of a century
um and Peter Hitchens writes about this
brilliantly in um the rage against God
brilliant book he talks about how how
have we gone from being
this kind of country with its massive
Christian Heritage
and then suddenly like all of the
institutions and all the things of
society and that's all just Fallen away
and he sort of charts brilliantly that
certain events that happen during the
last century that really kind of uh it's
it's kind of like you you know what you
were saying in your thread about how
people lost trust in it
um in institutions the same thing
happened with Christianity over the
course of uh you know a few decades you
know with the wars and the sewers crisis
and the female Affair and all these
different things
um so the point is I think we we said
around the 60s given some of these
crises
I think the world should be like this
and I don't like the reality of the way
the world is and I'm going to live in
accordance with that and then you see
the sexual sexual Revolution obviously
which we've covered with brilliant
people like Louise Perry and Mary
Harrington just doing such a brilliant
job and Mary epistad too yeah Mary
epistat yep um top level Cruiser
um yeah loads of people
um have been writing about this now
which is again
they tried the trans experiment it was
so extreme it's failing it's crumbling I
think what we're seeing now is what's
happening in the wake of that last best
part of a century of just let's do
things our way let's completely reject
God and the way he says that things that
life should be ordered in accordance
with thriving let's say that you know
let's throw out marriage let's throw out
um people taking responsibility for
children let's take let's throw out um
you know sex is just
you know it's just a pleasure activity
at the end of the day and we should be
able to have that and placing that as
the highest good in society the highest
value is like freedom and sexual you
know fulfillment
and then the repercussions of that you
know
Downstream are massive in terms of like
um you know people women's unhappiness
in terms of the Dayton Market trying to
have sex like like men as it were in
terms of no strings attached and and you
know trying to be this empowered sexual
being when they don't
inside a lot of them don't want that
they want to be with a man who's
committed to them and have a
relationship and have children and build
a family and build a home in a community
that's what most women want and I think
probably a lot of men want as well
um and then you've got you know the
other Downstream consequences which are
really sad like the like abortion and
just like if you if you say the highest
value in society is that I should be
able to have sex whomever I want and you
know that's the most that's the highest
priority that's the highest value
then you know the it's almost like
obligatory then that a child's life
should be sacrificed because of that
because it's like well that's that's my
right that's the most important thing
comes before responsibility and anything
else so we're seeing all these uh you
know repercussions come out of it
um and I'm sure that many people will
disagree with me and that's fine I don't
mind talking and debating with anyone
but what I'm saying is
we tried an experiment of
rejecting God I think and rejecting the
inheritance of Christianity that had
been brought down over hundreds and
hundreds of years and I think that's
failing in many ways but again in the
same way I'm encouraged about the the
trans thing failing I think I've seen a
lot of people
interested in Christianity again and I
think that
we've seen a lot of people talking about
it more freely immorally and I think a
lot of people
um
interested in pursuing it in a way that
they weren't before and I've seen a lot
of people
coming to Christ whoever completely no
background in it whatsoever
um and I think if you're if you'll uh
permit me to have one more minute
um the
so I talked about the trans thing as a
microcosm of like what's happened over
the last century I think that is a
microcosm of The Human Experience the
human problem which is
um you know if you if you want to look
at history if you want to look at the
Old Testament the
if you don't know what the Old Testament
is in the Bible pretty much the story of
the old the Old Testament is
God gives people like says this is what
you know this is what's good and right
and everyone's like yeah let's do it and
then after a while they're like actually
I'm not going to do that they start
doing their own thing
uh everything goes wrong they repent and
turn back to God and the cycle goes on
and on and on that's like the human
problem and I think that we're seeing
that come around again
foreign